[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست لو قلت لك
على طول هتقول لي اما يا مور فاهلا بيك في
حلقه جديده لعلم سحري ومميز جدا عالم
الموتى عارف انك دلوقتي بتقول ازاي موته
وعالم سحري ومميز في نفس الوقت لو شفت
فيلم كوكو هتكون فاهم قصدي ولو ما شفتوش
فيلا عشان اخدك الرحله اللي هناك رحله
عظمه ديزني وبيكسار انيميشن ستوديوز
وتنفيذهم لفيلم كوكو هو ايه الحكايه كان
يا مكان مجال ريفيرا شكله طفل مكسيكي عادي
عنده 12 سنه بس كان عنده حلم كبير في
حياته انه يبقى موسيقي كبير ومشهور ولامع
ويكون زي الموسيقي الشهير ونجم السينما
ارنستو ديلاكروز وايه المشكله
ان الموسيقى محظوره في عيلته وده بسبب ان
جدهم الاكبر تخلى عن العيله بسبب حبه
للموسيقى ومن وقتها والموسيقى ممنوعه بكل
اشكالها جوه عيله ريفيرا وممنوع حتى على
افرادها يروحوا الساحه اللي مليانه
مزيكتاتيه مجال بيحاول مع اهله بكل
الاشكال لكن العيله مهنتهم كلهم في صناعه
الاحذيه وما حدش بيسمع لمجال غير الجده
الاكبر كوكو كوكو هي بطل القصه اللي اتعمل
باسمها الفيلم اشمعنا وليه على الرغم ان
ظهورها محدود في الفيلم ده اللي هتعرفه
قدامه اهلا جل بيعرفوا انه بيحاول يقدم في
مسابقه الموسيقى اللي بتتعمل في المكسيك
خلال مهرجان
لتكريم وتذكر الموتى وهنا جدت مجال لابو
ويلتا بتثور عليه وبتكسر الجيتار الخشبي
بتاعه مجال بيهرب للساحه وبيحاول يشترك في
المسابقه لكن ما بيعرفش لان لازم يكون معك
هيحاول ليستعير جيتار لكنه هيفشل فبيقرر
يسرق جيتار
وفي اللحظه دي بتتغير مسار الاحداث تماما
مجال هيصاب بلعنا وبسببها هيبقى يشوف
الاموات ايه اللي بيحصل بقى خلال احداث
الفيلم مصير مجال ايه هيرجع ازاي رحلته في
عالم الموتى شكلها عامل ايه كل ده هتعرفه
لما تشوف الفيلم وانا هنا النهارده مش
هحكي لك عن الفيلم لان مهما حكيت عنه لازم
تشوفه بكل تفاصيل المبهره بس احكي لك عن
مشاهد جوه الفيلم ومواقف محتاجين نتكلم
عنها شويه اما اطلع
من البدايه ان هو مختلف عن افراد عيلته
وده اللي كان بيحركه ناحيه الموسيقى
واقتناعه واصراره زاد اكتر لما دانتي
الكلب بتاعه وقع الصور من اعلى اوفر جراند
وفتح مجال صوره الجده ايميل ده ولقى ان
جدو الاكبر كان معاه جيتار في الصوره
وقتها مجل طلع بكل حماس يشارك عيلته انه
قرر يبقى موسيقي زي جدو الاكبر لكنه
بيتصدم من رد فعلهم والجد اموالتها بتقول
له
[موسيقى]
جزء من العيله يعني انك هنا من اجل العيله
لكن مجال بيرفض ده تماما وبيفتكر مقوله
والنجاح هنا لا ياتي بالمجان عليك ان تفعل
كل ما يلزم لاغتنام اللحظه وده اللي عمله
مجل واغتنم اللحظه الفيلم بيدور عن اهميه
العيله والتمسك بالعادات والتقاليد فالطفل
اللي ما كانش بيهتم بتقاليد يوم الموتى
ولا تعليق صور العيله على الاوفر راند لما
اروح اعلم الموتى ادرك اهميه ان العيله
تفضل فاكراك وان انا مش بنموت فعلا لما
بنفارق الحياه لكن بنموت لما اللي بنحبهم
ينسونا ويبطلوا يفتكرونا علشان كده في
نهايه الفيلم بتوصل لنتيجه مهمه
طب ليه فيلم كوكو طلع بالعظمه دي بكل مشهد
مذهل فيه خليني اشاركك حقائق عن فيلم كوكو
استغرق انتاج الفيلم ست سنين كامله لشركه
بيكسار
فضل يشتغل على الفيلم من سبتمبر 2011 وده
نفس الفريق اللي اشتغل لمده اربع سنين على
فيلم
فريق الانتاج فضل لمده سنه يبحث ويذاكر
بشكل مفصل جدا الثقافه المكسيكيه
وديتوس لان القصه تم تنفيذها واتطورت بناء
على ثقافه وعادات اهل المكسيك الكلب دانتي
صديق ميجال في الفيلم هو كلب حقيقي استوحى
فريق الانتاج شخصيه الكلب دانتي من فصيله
كلاب معروفه في المكسيك باسم شيلوي فيلم
كوكو دمج انواع موسيقيه مكسيكيه مختلفه
زيرا والقصائد المستوحاه من كلاسيكيات
العصر الذهبي للسينما المكسيكيه وده اللي
خل الفيلم مميز جدا لانه مش فيلم موسيقي
لكن المزيكا والكلمات دايما كانت بتحكي
قصه مميزه في الفيلم وزادت من ترابط
الاحداث ميغيل كان منبهر بالبطل بتاعه
ارناستو ديلاكروز علشان كده صناعه الفيلم
ابتكرواز حياه كامله علشان تقدر كمشاهد
تعرفوا اكتر وتتعلق بكل تفاصيله صناع
ابتكروا شخصيه ارناستو ديلاكروز مع فكره
انه كان معاصر لخورخي نجرات وبيدرو
انفانتي وخفيرسولاس تقع سانتا سيسيليا
المدينه العشريه الابطال بشكل اساسي في
سانتا فيدل
لما منتجين وصناع الفيلم اشتغلوا على
الفيلم كوكو وكان مهتمين بكل تفصيله مهما
كانت في اختيار المكان زار مدن كثيره جدا
في المكسيك علشان يستوحوا من المدينه
الانسب لقصتهم وفي النهايه اختاروا بالشكل
الاساسي لانهم كانوا بيدوروا على مدينه
تبدو تاريخيه علشان يظهروا مرور الاجيال
المختلفه خلالها كل الجداريات اللي ظهرت
بشكل مبهر في فيلم مستوحاه من فنانين
مكسيكيين اصليين خاصه
فنانين بيكسار استلهموا من اسلوبهم لعناصر
معينه في الفيلم هتلاحظها اكتر في ارض
الموتى في النهايه الفيلم نجح نجاح الساحق
حق الفيلم ايرادات بقيمه 9 مليون دولار في
نهايه عطله الاسبوع الافتتاحيه وبكده يكون
اكبر رقم سجله فيلم رسوم متحركه اصلي في
اول اسبوع من افتتاحه كما كان اكبر ظهور
لفيلم رسوم متحركه خارج موسم الصيف
السينمائي في السوق في عطله نهايه الاسبوع
التانيه حقق الفيلم ايرادات اخرى بقيمه 10
مليون دولار بزياده 12% عن عطله نهايه
الاسبوع الاولى ليصل الى اجمالي ايرادات
بقيمه 28 مليون دولار بالرقم ده كان فيلم
كوكو الاعلى على الاطلاق من حيث الايرادات
اللي جمعها فيلم واحد خلال 10 ايام في
المكسيك وكمان كان فيلم الرسوم المتحركه
الاعلى دخلا في البلد تجاوز فيلم كوكو
فيلم المنتقمون وبكده اصبح الفيلم الاكثر
دخلا في السوق المكسيكيه الحقيقه فيلم
كوكو مش بس اثر في تاريخ السينما
المكسيكيه لكنه اثر على كل انتاجات ديزني
وبكسار ويعتبر واحد من افضل منتجه الفيلم
مليان تفاصيل مبهره جدا ومشاعر مختلفه
محبه للعيله وقت مش هتنساه شوف الفيلم
دلوقتي واستناني الحلقه اللي جايه مع فيلم
جديد من بودكا الافلام المقدم من العربيه
[موسيقى]